I'll sit back through so we're gonna
start distracting her without me you
don't know oh us mean I know I say we
will try distracting her oh all right oh
good yes the game will automatically do
these things you just keep going don't
look at the alien nice nice so she
brought that special star yes that's a
skill star I'll show you where that
comes into play ooh they were moving Oh
what keep going so wait like it's so far
zoomed out that you kind of have to use
the rhythm but you're not using that yet
sometimes you have visual indicators but
this throws you off your game and tries
to mess it up alkaline have a head
change is perfect every time the cameras
off oh oh nice that was the last one
well done Sam that was good that was
really good and so what's interesting
about this whole thing is you know that
you know going through these games each
different rhythm game is a different so
yes because they gave you a score at the
end yet the capacitor certain threshold
then they give you like a superb Roy got
a high score and at the bottom it even
shows you like these little coins and
don't worry I'll show you that guy at
the bottom so real quick before we move
on go and look at the bottom so that guy
the same is Tibby a real quick touch
point we're gonna go to first contacts
yes oh that's cool so real quick about
tipping hippin backup ethic it's like
three or four-year risk it yeah good
there's all these little like you know
rhythm games the play and the whole
story by thur is actually the first one
with the story so really quickly tibia
soul do with like this pink afro and
then by like please fail this tutorial
please okay I ask you terribly thank you
our viewers benefit ready and tank yeah
so tibi is trying to get back to rhythm
world and in order to get back there you
need to help him complete these kind of
you know rhythm games and press these
buttons and kind of do all those things
for him so you can't generate enough
energy get back to rhythm world so it's
a must
I'm gonna fail the tutorial yeah I
wouldn't feel it yeah he's failed
straight up so when this game works
elephant so the way this game works is
actually repeat after it so the dot dot
it's wait dot dot dot so now notice on
the bottom screen it has this grid so
for people that are kind of new to the
franchise or if you're kind of wondering
where am I supposed to hit a need some
kind of visual indicator when the game
will actually pull in some things yeah
they'll pull it up for you you can see
where like yes which ones you get which
ones you missed okay Haley just like
know personally though I will have a
disclaimer I like failing things on
purpose i get a mostly wrong line right
but this one in particular i really love
failing to 10 songs yeah because
basically you are an astronaut who's
translating this alien language for the
people of Earth who her for rhythm world
and when you mess it up you basically
the sports the translation which is
hilarious yep it's good translation
please wait very nice Oh
eyes on the music is just so infectious
in this game yeah else I kind of quietly
underneath this um so you guys can kind
of hear the music yeah you're bobbing
your head that's good it's actually
really catchy because one of the guys
that helped create this music is name's
Suki and is a really popular a really
popular music producer in Japan any help
craft all these tunes so they're they're
crafted to be really catchy like you're
listening to it there's always please
it's all those people looking around
like wait yep oh there you go hey please
nice likes arms grooving whether I know
oh oh that was clean and everybody Wow I
love the art style in this game but
there's somebody just really cute fun
characters mm-hmm hey you up there the
loading guys adorable it as you go
through kind of each of the you know
different rhythm games like this kind of
aesthetic until I something to go and
you mailed that too that was really good
feel like I'm setting myself up for a
terrible fall no no you're doing great
you keep that up six points you got the
skill star and no miss bonus so she got
extra point correct and i'll even go
into what we can spend those coins on a
little bit later on so let's do boo
tongue-lashing i think it's the next one
up yeah all right timing all right oh
this is so good okay so um we talking
about you mentioned you see I mentioned
some food mentioned oh right the art
style start style cool takeuchi one of
the guys that I'm really you know almost
like a little warioware ish mmm it's
very you know to have this little quirky
feel two things but I'm yeah it's super
super cute and you'll have to meet all
kinds of really weird characters and
they're they're really cute this is
really like awesome and I have my
favorites but I'm sure you'll find your
own all right so here we go so the game
in this one you can kind of tell it's
just trying to make sure that she
presses the a button right on button
where the yellow stuff is up exactly he
has the cards as weapons they're
actually really cute yeah it is i spin
well he's like well his eyes go apart
it's actually really tempting to mess up
look at the animation on the characters
when you do something wrong is really
fun son has to just like annoyed at you
and there's what you do hi you should
like for this one I like missing the
very last note in this one oh yeah I
might be able to indulge you
okay so the red ones different as soon
as you hit sound one two three so it's
on for once you hear that the perfect
science you guys have you guys got that
at home okay you can follow along I'll
kind of back off and let lets in groove
it I had extra coffee actually just
before the segment just read you see mmm
thank you there you go
the funnies like me and Erica like
noticeably tapping a button if there's
like an that phase it is silly gray like
you don't this foot it's like this do it
Oh
who
Oh salad mugers that was legit please
jump in Sam oh my goodness oh man you're
rocking it man I don't even like can't
touch that man is so good so you hit all
of them but you gotta know miss on this
but you still only got 89 because your
timing wasn't awesome perfect on all of
them so there's so much depth like you
can play this you know bird hours just
to try to perfect it and hold man ya
gotta nail like right the center there
is absolutely hard yeah and it's super
super tight that windows real committee
so guess who I'm a lumberjack I like
that let me find it there is all right
are you gonna love this one guys so uh
you know for people that know the rhythm
have a series where this is your first
time watching it you know this
particular game rhythm heaven megamix is
really a mix of like they're these you
know the game boy advance games that
never made the u.s. they put them in
here there's a brand new rhythm games
that are you know that are that are in
this for the first time and then there's
also some returning favorites from kind
of the the DS game and the wii game for
people that know that one and some of
them even have like different music so i
mean this is really i mean there's no
better time to jump into rhythm heaven
and you know whenever this comes out so
at that point you know if you haven't
tried it man like you're missing out
because this is 0 practicing over there
so real quick so while she's focusing of
course you you know if the law gets put
down in front of this bear and he just
kind of swing you speaking once four
small logs twice in a row for big logs
there you go I guess I dispute
suspenders are boss suspenders are also
your sassy looking at axe chopping bear
that's right it's very spout for a bear
is this nothing shape he is I mean dude
you for chopping wood all day you'd be
sold to their be totally hoped out
out of what keep going that's always the
ruling rhythm have it no matter what
just keep going so the only indication
but in the music is no indication that a
big log is coming let me basically it's
the visual indication and obviously it
makes a different sound because you're
you're headed trifling correct so some
games actually give you a different
audio indicator like that when you put
the can down it may be made a different
sound right if it was a larger thing up
Eva's only visual other games will
actually you know wouldn't do it no oh
man so not distracting at all they're
ready he okay listen up okay check this
out I'd be told that we're launching
rhythm heaven megamix right now so if
you want to go on blitz thing this game
is live this game is life right now I'm
totally downloading this like at home
and or back I get my uh like a motel
rooms I need this all the time and it
back but you know so nice they're
actually uh the one thing if you're this
is your first time playing you know
really happen or if you just want to get
into it and you can't even like you know
you just I don't know if I want to try
it out we could do this there's either
this demo that goes live also so
download the free demo you can give some
a shot and it's gonna be awesome too
running theme I think your house live is
your fire but not your money glories of
happy vampire I think it Chico yeah um
how about sumo sumo sumo man confessed
in the lush tower except break out what
we had that yeah it's a thicket 44th
from the boat left out yeah because it
thanks yeah oh yeah so they gets a
second from the top dandy your cold
array to my brothers oh you're gonna
like this one too I do okay on this for
me visit the goat next movie yeah you
want to yes yeah if you want to yeah
alright alright so the key here is a
little bit different there's there's
different patterns for this one so the
first pattern is you're going to see it
here but once the dog gives us know the
four counts you tough keep pressing a
button you know with the tempo just to
give you a chance to kind of sync up to
the rhythm tubes definitely early there
and I could graduate adjust to get
closer to the right timing oh yeah you
got to watch the dog for this part
that's I always always doesn't go
watching the dog he'll give you all your
cues for this that's how it was slower
I'm sorry bounces you are kind of
stomping like you know 600 pounds of man
is in front of that dog so I love how
okay but Lulu sumo wrestler has glasses
so you think you just get contact you
know it's so kind of a rough sport oh
look but maybe he knows that he's just
slapping and not actually trying to push
the other guy out right I got like no
face contact here
and this space between notes so now wait
that's full four counts boom oh wait i
love the expression on that person the
wrestler when you get yeah the front his
I feel a big like we were supposedly
choose all right real deal we're doing
this for real all right i should i
really like the music in this one to
remember being really catchy because if
you listen there's some some dude
singing in the back to
and I love how the actions you take
become part of the music no talking
about yes we have basically they're
they're stomps are kind of like the bass
drum and then you have the slaps it's
kind of like a snare and it's all
written into the music to it like you
know it's gonna change here right you
know what changes here and here nice
oh I can't wait for you guys to play
these man
look a look at the camera like you see
11 GS lemon
tell atop his glasses oh man it's a
couple there though that was what slaps
that's mine oh yeah 91 that's killing it
you're on you're like so good at this
game is sleep you're on a roll here I
don't know what I mess up your flow is
what makes me mad no you're doing good
positive energy you got this all right
look uh yes are you up for remix I could
yeah okay sure just to go first to be
doing this we got to see that girl what
are you to go he's gonna go it's go to
go a beaut so what we're gonna do is Rex
we're gonna back out into the cafe and
the cafe does all things you can do so
one of them is here you taught the
barista love him yeah also see this go
um so we're gonna head pics and turn em
so we're gonna feed this go so and those
turnips are going to replenish over time
as you play yes just keep playing a much
gets horrendous but you can also go
technically you could also kind of pay
for turnips with your coins so yeah
let's do that so go ahead and hit left
ready yep speed in the good time okay
but if we're gonna feed this goat don't
ask she'll feed us go did she do yeah
and then we're gonna be turn for the
goat we're gonna kind of slingshot
almost like a like a mini pinball
machine nice sauce that's good one who
try to aim for that go very nice taste
look at that and then the pattern is
gonna change so you're gonna have to
switch up your strategy a little yeah so
sometimes like the little kind of the
nubs will actually change where they are
to have to kind of become where that is
the goat may actually move to a
different position so you may have to
figure out where you know
Oh get amount of time like you know how
long the charge or shop or you let it go
and I pretty good let's go you think you
couldn't care about this hit some hit
right get right on your own yeah yeah I
forget me how many more don't think I do
there were those try yeah you're some
points that's what all right we're gonna
spend some coins and we're gonna
actually do some expensive turnips here
and they're alternating these green and
silver turnips and I'm a trying it but
with again it's fine just know that
bloody kids ever you see the goat on the
top screen the right side let's see that
kind of bar that goes up when that bar
reaches to level 10 sir philip obviously
past level 89 and if you get to level 10
you actually can unlock is really
interesting a little like loading icons
so as the game is loading you can you
know if you want to lock when it was a
little like icons just in the right
bottom right corner and it could be a
character's could be a really random
stuff so again a lot of fun when i
leveled up the board change to so i have
to kind of revisit my strategy this is
goes wandering up to you sit sit go to
your eyes ah ok i wanted to go fever
cookie what's available now Steven go
see go fever write this out yeah go go
fever we're gonna get it eventually I
think shy keep going ahead of um let's
help you just notice yeah you can see
the go for that thank you he's kind of
just taken in yes he's kind of he's kind
of happy now uh yeah lift up to a
junction remix let's do you want to
citrus yeah you don't have a lot of time
left but we might be no oh man so this
may be probably lay everything we're
almost out so let's go and finish the
remix long story short these remixes um
you know if he's a mix is kind of
combine all of these different kind of
games that you learn along the way and
they put them in rapid-fire succession
so you have to kind of don't worry
you'll know them all before going in
have to kind of figure it out what would
it keep going right so these are all
mini-games from other earn not minigames
what are we going to rhythm it's awesome
good rhythm games it from from other
parts of the game but they mash them all
together under this orange theme so they
all have this orange theme that they
wouldn't otherwise
nice oh we remember this well that's a
tough transition
who take out
here you go swimming bowls in a soda and
that's it man that's the three mixes a
ton of different music games and looking
games dude it is and it's out now well
now right now right now surprise all
right nice job Sam wait a rocket I'm
sure he's really good and that is a wrap
I think works enough for this but we're
going to come back in just a second and
say goodbye because you know it's time
parting is such sweet sorrow and it's
time to do so but we've had a lot of fun
so we'll be right